-Thank you.
I -- so, I'm not famous.
But if I look familiar,
it's because I look exactly like
the emoji guy
that's like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm also dressed like this
so I look like a bouncer
at a "Ted" talk.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm from Wisconsin,
if you can tell that
by my accent and stuff.
Whoo.
Um, yeah.
But New Yorkers don't know how
to receive my energy.
They're always like,
"Hey, what's that on your face?"
And I'm like, "It's a smile."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I have joy in my heart.
And then I give it all away
every day.
And then I wake up the next day
and I'm like, "Oh there's more."
[ Light laughter ]
Because that's what it feels
like to be not from New York.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I wish I was a more rugged,
bad boy.
You know, like, no women ever
look at me like, "Oh, man.
I bet Pete's going to ravage me
all night."
[ Laughter ]
But there are woman
that look at me like,
"I bet Pete has good
penmanship."
[ Laughter ]
You know, and I do.
I mean, look at my face.
I'm tall, dark, and pleasant.
[ Laughter ]
I look like I stay in shape
by only flying kites.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Dude, you are getting
jacked."
"Yeah, it's been gusty."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You don't even know."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And women always say
that they want a bad boy.
Well, my whole thing is,
no, you don't.
[ Laughter ]
You don't.
Right?
Which would you rather have,
a guy that's like,
"Oh, my God, your rack looks
great in that dress."
Or would you rather have me
who's like,
"Oh, my God,
that dress has pockets."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Women love dresses with pockets.
If you love a woman and you want
to blow her mind,
go steal her favorite dress
out of the closet.
Take it to a tailor,
have him install pockets.
[ Light laughter ]
Take her out on her dream date
and in the middle of the date,
be like,
"Hey, honey, can you put
my Chapstick in your pocket?"
And she'll be like,
"What, I don't have any pockets
in this --
oh, my God, there's pockets!"
[ Laughter ]
"Pockets!"
I really got into that one.
[ Laughter ]
I think I'm a sensitive guy
because I grew up
idolizing my dad.
I was like,
"That's what's men are like,
and I want to be like that."
The only problem is my dad
was an interior decorator.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, my dad gave me
my "Y" chromosome.
It's just mine was in cursive.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was a good one.
[ Laughter ]
All my friends, they had cool
redneck dads growing up.
You know, they'd be like,
"My dad is taking me hunting
this weekend."
I'd be like, "Oh mine, too,
you know, for bargains."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I got a deer."
I'd be like, "I got an ottoman."
[ Laughter ]
I remember one time, one of my
friends, he goes,
"My dad taught me
how to catcall women."
And I was,
"Oh, just as important,
my dad taught me that women
are people."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, right?
Who knew that until last year,
right?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did.
I knew the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
I knew my whole life.
Oh, I'm such a feminist.
Oh, cripes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I'm such a feminist,
I don't even use those
credit-card-chip readers
until it tells me that I can.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have you ever tried to put
your card in too early?
It's like, quack-quack-quack.
I'm like --
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm not a bad guy, all right?
[ Laughter ]
I respect you.
I hate conflict,
but I got into a tussle today.
I know, you guys are like,
"Wow, this guy tussles."
Oh, yeah, I do.
[ Laughter ]
I tussle a tidbit.
I got into a tussle
with a motion-sensor sink.
Isn't that the worst technology?
Because I'm just standing there
waving my hand.
Like, how pale am I?
[ Laughter ]
This things looking at my hand
like,
"No, that's just more sink."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm standing there
waving my hand.
It's giving me no water.
But for some reason
motion-sensor hand foam is like,
"Eer-ree, eer-ree.
I'm here for you, buddy.
Eer-ree, eer-ree."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like,
"I can't use you yet
because I don't have water
from your friend."
[ Laughter ]
"Eer-ree."
Uh, paper towels are like,
"Rrr-rrr-rrr."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why do motion-sensor sinks work,
like, 4% of the time?
But if you are sitting down
on a motion-sensor toilet,
and even one flake of lint
floats into that stall,
you are like, "Oh, nooo."
Motion-sensor toilet is like,
"Gotcha."
[ Imitates water splashing ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's shooting Niagara Falls
temperature mist into your butt.
[ Laughter ]
It feels like a thousand
dog noses
are nuzzling your butt cheeks.
All right, guys, I'm Pete Lee.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! Yeah!
Oh!
Pete Lee right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my face hurts.
For more, visit petelee.net.